>> WHAT UP, EVERYBODY, WELCOME
TO THE SHOW.
WE ARE HERE, GUYS.
WE ARE HERE.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING TODAY?
>> NO COMPLAINTS, MAN.
CHRISTMAS WAS GOOD.
GOT A NEW PARIS KICKS.
EVERYONE IS HEALTHY.
EVERYONE IS HAPPY.
JUST HAVE TO WIN SOME BETS.
THAT'S ALL THAT'S LEFT.
>> DID YOU GET WHAT YOU WANT
TO?
HOW WAS I GOING?
>> WELL, I WANTED JORDAN POOLE
TO MAKE 3+3 LAST WEEK AS AN
EARLY CHRISTMAS PRESENT, AND I
DIDN'T GET THAT.
THAT KIND OF RUINED MY HOLIDAY
SEASON, I WON'T LIE.
JUST BEING HONEST.
>> ON BOTH OF OUR SHOWS, YOU
ARE KNOWN AS THE I TOLD YOU SO
GUY.
I JUST WANT TO LET YOU AND INDY
NO, THROUGHOUT LAST WEEK I TOLD
YOU ABOUT JORDAN POOLE AND
THOSE THREES.
I TOLD YOU.
BUT THAT IS OKAY.
THAT'S OKAY.
BECAUSE TODAY WE ARE GOING TO
GET RIGHT.
I'M FEELING GOOD.
WE ARE GOING TO GET RIGHT.
>> HOLD ON, GREG.
I BRANDED MYSELF AS NOT AND I
TOLD YOU SO GUY.
I AM NOT AND I TOLD YOU SO GUY.
>> I KNOW THAT'S ACCURATE.
>> WHETHER IT'S ACCURATE OR
NOT, THAT'S WHAT I BRAND MYSELF
AS.
>> I LOVE IT, I LOVE IT.
I DON'T KNOW.
WE HAVE TO ASK THE AUDIENCE IF
THEY BRAND YOU AS THAT.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES THAT
MAKE THE DECISIONS.
YOU KNOW, YOU MIGHT THINK THAT
IS WHAT YOU ARE BRANDED AS, BUT
COME ON THE SHOW AND YOU
CONSTANTLY SAY I TOLD YOU SO, I
TOLD YOU SO.
>> SPEAKING OF THE AUDIENCE, I
WANT TO SHOUT OUT THE THOMPSON,
WHO JUMPED IN HERE BEFORE THE
SHOW STARTED AND SAID I JUST
WANT TO SAY I WAS RIGHT ABOUT
MY NUGGETS AND JOKIC.
THOMPSON, HE IS THE I TOLD YOU
SO GUY.
SHOUT OUT TO HIM.
HE WAS RIGHT.
>> TODAY'S VERSION OF I TOLD
YOU SO GUY, SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING A LOYAL FAN
TO THE SHOW.
LET ME INTRODUCE EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS GREG RB.
NEXT TO ME IS THE MAN I CALL
HIM P. MIXED HIM AS THE MAN WE
LIKE TO CALL AROUND HERE
PRODUCER RYAN.
LAST WEEK WE BUILT OUR FIVE LEG
PARLAY, SO TODAY WE ARE RUNNING
IT BACK.
BUT WE HAVE GOT TO SEE ONE GO
THROUGH THE BASKET.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS DROP YOUR
BEST BET FOR TONIGHT IN THE
CHAT AND WE WILL COOK THEM INTO
A PARLAY.
RYAN, TALK TO US.
WE GAVE THE CHAT AND AMPLE
AMOUNT OF TIME TO FILL IN SOME
COMMENTS. WHAT ARE THEY TALKING
ABOUT.
>> IS WANT TO TOSS OUT HERE
QUICKLY, BECAUSE WE'RE USUALLY
ONLY TNT GAMES.
THERE ARE NO TNT GAMES TONIGHT.
SO THE BOARD IS OURS.
WE HAVE MUCH AT OUR DISPOSAL.
LOOK AT US.
GUYS, LOOK AT US.
WE HAVE GAMES THERE, IF YOU ARE
ON THE EAST COAST, WE HAVE
GAMES TO THE 10:00 HOUR.
LOOK AT THEM.
I CAN KEEP SCROLLING.
SO WHATEVER YOU GUYS WANT, BE
THOMPSON, VERY BIG ON JOKIC
TONIGHT.
>> AS HE SHOULD DAY.
>> ALSO, MAYBE NOT THE SHOW TO
TALK ABOUT IT, BUT SNEAKY
THREE.
KIND OF HEARING IT.
>> I COULD SEE IT.
I CAN SEE IT.
THE WAY HE IS PLAYING, I CAN
DEFINITELY SEE IT.
HE HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY BALLER.
ABSOLUTELY BALLER.
>> YOU PUT UP 40 POINTS IN 27
REBOUNDS.
>> YOU ONLY NEED TO DO THAT A
HANDFUL OF TIMES TO GET PEOPLE
TO NOTICE.
RYAN, DO YOU SEE ANYTHING THAT
CATCHES YOUR ATTENTION?
WE HAVE TO LOCK IN ONE LEG AREA
AND IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
CATCHES YOUR ATTENTION, OR DID
YOU THINK OF ANYTHING BEFORE
THE SHOW?
YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE LOOKING
FOR HERE.
WE ARE ONLY LOOKING FOR SCOOPS.
>> I ALWAYS THINK THINGS BUT
YOU ALWAYS PUT ME ON BLAST
BEFORE THE SHOW STARTS SO I
DECIDED NOT TO SHARE WITH YOU.
I THINK TODAY MAY BE THE DAY
THAT WE CHOOSE ASIDE IN A GAME.
I THINK THAT IS WHERE I LAND.
BULL RUN SAYS REMEMBER THIS IS
A PARLAY SO WE DON'T NEED TO GO
CRAZY WITH THE WHOLE TAKING AN
UNDERDOG MONEYLINE.
WE COULD TAKE SOME CHALK IF WE
WANT, BUT BULL RUN SAYS WIZARDS
MONEYLINE.
WE HAVE DANTE CASH SAYS SPENCER
DINWIDDIE, 15+ POINTS.
I SEE IT TAKE FROM JD 804 ABOUT
AUSTIN REEVES, AND I SAW THE
WORD OVER.
AUSTIN REEVES IS BAND.
BAND.
WAYNE 60.
JOKIC OVER NINE ASSISTS.
LAKERS PLUS FOR. I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU GUYS FEEL ABOUT BETTING
ON THE LAKERS, BUT THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING I'M INTERESTED IN.
>> IT IS THE MAGIC.
>> ON THE ROAD.
I DON'T KNOW.
THIS FEELS LIKE A TRENDY PICK.
I HAVE SEEN IT ON TWITTER A
LITTLE BIT.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THEY ARE NOT
CLOSER.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD SAY IS
THEY SHOULD WIN THAT GAME.
BUT THAT IS RANDOM.
>> I SEE A SCOOP.
I SEE A SCOOP.
PABLO BANCHERO , 20+ POINTS.
>> NOT A SCOOP, IT IS A PLAY.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE.
>> THAT IS A SCOOP, RIGHT
THERE.
SCOOPS, PLAYS, YEAH.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
BUT A SCOOP CAN BE A PLAY.
>> THAT IS FAIR.
THAT'S FAIR.
I WILL TAKE IT.
>> SAYS HE WANTS TO SHOW OFF IN
FRONT OF LeBRON SO HE LIKES
PABLO BANCHERO.
MAYBE THAT IS A SCOOP .
>> THAT IS ENOUGH FOR ME.
I'M COOL WITH THIS.
>> I LIKE IN BE.
HE KNOWS HOW TO MAKE IT FLOW.
JUST ADD TO IT, I THINK FOR SURE
PABLO BANCHERO IS ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR.
HE HAS HAD A OF A SEASON . I
THINK THEY ARE PROBABLY ONE
PLAYER AWAY FROM ACTUALLY
MAKING THE PLAYOFFS AND BEING A
TEAM THAT MAKES NOISE.
IF WE WANT TO LOCK IN PABLO, I
AM ALL OVER IT.
IT IS NOT A GET BAD PLAY, AT
ALL.
>> THERE IT IS.
THERE IT IS.
WE ARE FEELING GOOD.
RYAN, I KNOW YOU ARE A MAN OF
THE PEOPLE.
BUT I AM IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW, AND I SEE TYREE'S
HALLIBURTON, 35 POINTS, REBOUNDS
, AND ASSISTS.
THAT WAS GIVEN TO US BY THE REAL
KR 215.
AND THAT ONE CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION.
WE DON'T HAVE TO RIDE WITH IT,
BUT THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S
PARLAY.
AND THAT ONE CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION.
YOU GUYS LIKE IT?
DO YOU GUYS WANT TO CONSIDER
IT?
I WILL NEED INPUT.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
I'M SURE AS EVERYONE KNOWS,
LAST WEEK THEY CALLED TYRESE
HALIBURTON  OUT AND SAID HE WAS
A WANT TO BE ALL-STAR.
EVERYTHING HE HAS DONE AFTER
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY COOK.
HE HAD 10 THREES IN A GAME NOT
TOO LONG AGO, OVER 40 POINTS.
HE IS ONE OF THE BETTER PLAYERS
OF THE PACERS HAVE GOT.
PRO IS ONE OF THE BEST PLAYERS
ON THE TEAM, TO BE HONEST.
I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK HE IS VERY MUCH IN THE
LIMELIGHT RIGHT NOW AND I THINK
HE HAS SOMETHING TO PROVE AFTER
GETTING TRIPPED AT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE PRA IS THE
MOVE FOR THE PARLAY, BUT
DEFINITELY SOMETHING WE SHOULD
TALK ABOUT.
>> I'M WITH IT.
I AM GOING TO LOOK AT HIS
REBOUND AND ASSIST NUMBERS FOR
THE PAST FEW GAMES.
BUT I AGREE ON THE SOMETHING TO
PROVE.
ALSO, SOME REALLY HIGH-LEVEL
ANALYSIS HERE.
THE HAWKS STINK.
THEY ARE NOT GOOD.
SO I'M COOL WITH THIS.
JUST BECAUSE I THINK THE HAWKS
ARE NOT GOOD, AND HE IS THE
PACERS BEST PLAYER.
>> YOU WANT TO GIVE US SOME
RECENT GAMES ON THIS PRA?
>> I WOULD LOVE TO.
OF COURSE.
LAST GAME, NOT A GOOD ONE.
12 POINTS, ONE REBOUND, SIX
ASSISTS.
BUT BEFORE THAT.
43 POINTS.
I DON'T EVEN THINK I NEED TO
READ THE OTHER ONES.
BUT I WILL ANYWAY.
TWO REBOUNDS, SEVEN ASSISTS.
THE GAME BEFORE THAT, 33 POINTS.
THREE REBOUNDS, EIGHT ASSISTS.
HERE IS PLAYING THE PELICANS.
SAYS THE 27th.
>> RYAN JUST HAD A MALFUNCTION.
>> IT SAYS DECEMBER 27th.
IS TODAY NOT DECEMBER 27?
>> IT IS.
TODAY IS THE 27th.
>> OKAY, WELL THE APP I AM
USING NEEDS TO FIGURE IT OUT.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO WE GET THE
POINT.
HE HAS BEEN BAWLING.
ALSO CAME WITH THE SCOOP AND
SAID HE GOT CALLED OUT IN THE
MEDIA.
WE WILL JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT.
BECAUSE I DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT.
MY MAN HAS AND BAWLING.
SO LET'S ASK THE AUDIENCE.
DO WE WANT TO LOCK IN TYRESE
HALIBURTON  OVER 32.5?
>> IT IS 33.5.
>> OVER 33.5 POINTS, REBOUNDS,
ASSISTS.
WE NEED THUMBS UP IN THE
COMMENTS IF YOU GUYS LIKE IT.
THUMBS DOWN IN THE COMMENTS IF
YOU GUYS DO NOT LIKE IT.
>> JUST A LITTLE FEEDBACK FROM
THE CHAT. WAYNE 60 SAYS HE WAS
GARBAGE LAST NIGHT.
WE WENT OVER THAT, OBVIOUSLY,
BUT WITH DOLLAR CONFIRMING THEY
ARE IN THE SECOND GAME OF BACK
TO BACK.
SO MAYBE THAT MAKES US HESITATE
A LITTLE BIT.
I THINK THAT IS A GOOD WAY TO
HANDICAP SOME OF THESE GAMES.
ALSO WITH THE CHAT, THANKS.
>> YEAH.
THAT WAS GOING TO BE MY TAKE ON
SOME OF THESE.
>> MY MAN MIKE RITTER SEND, I
HOPE I AM SAYING IT RIGHT.
I THINK I AM SAYING IT RIGHT.
>> IT CAN'T BE ANY WORSE THAN
THE WAY I SAY JOKIC.
>> ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO.
WE ARE GETTING SOME FEEDBACK IN
THE COMMENTS.
I SEE A LOT OF COMES DOWN.
>> I DO TOO.
WE CAN MOVE ON.
WE HAVE AN ENTIRE SLATE.
WE HAVE ALL NIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT IS
GOING TO TAKE THEM TO KICK US
OFF THE SHOW.
BUT WE HAVE HAD SOME WEEKS
WHERE THEY HAVE KIND OF GOT TO
GET OUT OF CERTAIN TIME, I FEEL
LIKE WE CAN STRETCH OUR LEGS
TODAY.
SO BRING THE LOCKS IN HERE.
BRING THE LOCKS.
>> WE HAVE THE CHEF HAT ON, WE
ARE GOING TO COOK.
I SAW BEFORE THE HALLIBURTON
PLAY, JUMPING IN AND SAY
HOUSTON ROCKETS +15 AGAINST THE
BOSTON CELTICS.
THE ROCKETS ARE ON A BACK TO
BACK.
>> HOUSTON ROCKETS JUST BEAT
THE OUT OF THE BULLS LAST
NIGHT.
I AM OFFICIALLY BACK OUT ON MY
CHICAGO BULLS AFTER A FEW GOOD
GAMES BY THEM.
THE ROCKETS LOOKED GOOD LAST
NIGHT.
>> THE ROCKETS MIGHT BE GOOD.
THEY TRAVELED FROM CHICAGO TO
BOSTON.
15 POINTS IS A TON OF POINTS.
SO MANY.
>> THAT IS A TON OF POINTS, BUT
JOKIC.
THE COMMENTS  WERE TALKING
ABOUT IT.
HE HAS BEEN BAWLING.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
I FEEL LIKE THE POINTS,
REBOUNDS, AND ASSISTS SHOULD BE
EASY MONEY.
>> I THOUGHT REBOUNDS AND
ASSISTS AT 20+ WITH JOKIC.
WE WILL COME BACK TO OUR
BEAUTIFUL  HOUSTON ROCKETS IN A
LITTLE BIT.
BUT WE WILL GO TO JOKIC.
WE ARE NOT LEAVING OUR ROCKETS
ALONE.
WE WILL BE BACK .
>> WE NEED CONTEXT THERE.
BECAUSE VEGAS IS GIVING US 15
POINTS FOR A REASON.
AND IT IS THE ROCKETS FACING
YOUR CELTICS. SO WE NEED SOME
CONTEXT FROM YOU.
WE WILL PUT A PIN IN IT.
>> YEAH, WE WILL PUT A PIN IN
IT.
FROM B THOMPSON, I SAW OVER
20.5, I THINK IT WAS, REBOUNDS
AND ASSISTS.
AT 21.5.
HOW DO WE FEEL ABOUT THAT.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF WE NEED TO
LOCK IN ON THE REBOUNDS AND
ASSISTS ONLY.
I THINK THE PRA IS INTERESTING.
ALSO, I THINK JUST THE BOARDS.
HE HAS BEEN GETTING LIKE 15
BOARDS A GAME FOR THE THE LAST
WEEK.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF PLAYS IN
HERE, AND I'M DOUBLE CHECKING
RIGHT NOW, BUT I THINK HE MIGHT
BE HEARD.
WHO IS GOING TO GUARD HIM ON
THE KINGS?
>>, MIGHT AS WELL LOCK IN THE
PRA.
EVEN THOUGH IT IS A LOT, MY MAN
HAS BEEN BALLING . AND WHO IS
GOING TO GUARD HIM ON THE
KINGS?
LET'S REALLY THINK ABOUT IT.
I WILL LOOK AT THE KINGS ROSTER
AND WE CAN LITERALLY GO DOWN
THE ROSTER AND SEE WHO IS GOING
TO GUARD.
>> DID YOU GUYS SEE THE PRA?
IT IS AT 48.5.
>> OKAY, SO GO LOOK IT WHEN HE
HAS DONE AND THEN LET'S
COMPARE, LIKE WE DO EVERYBODY
ELSE.
WE DO IT TO EVERYBODY ELSE, WHY
CHANGE IT UP?
>> YEAH, BUT -- WHATEVER.
I WILL DO IT.
>> WE DO IT TO EVERYBODY.
>> HE DOESN'T GET THE EVERYBODY
TREATMENT.
>> I'M CONFUSED ON WHAT
TREATMENT HE SHOULD GET.
>> HE SCORED 41 POINTS LAST
GAME.
>> EXACTLY.
SO WHY ARE WE SCARED OF A 45.5
POINTS REBOUNDS?
>> BECAUSE DECEMBER 31st HE
SCORED 15 AGAINST MEMPHIS AND I
AM AFRAID THAT IS WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN HERE.
MEMPHIS HAS SOMEBODY THAT CAN
ACTUALLY GUARD HIM.
STEVEN ADAMS IS A BIG GUY.
JARED JACKSON IS A BIG GUY.
>> DEVILS ADVOCATE IS THAT THEY
MIGHT BLOW OUT THE KINGS
TONIGHT.
HE MAY ONLY PLAY THREE
QUARTERS.
THAT WOULD BE MY ONLY ARGUMENT
AGAINST.
BUT I AM KIND OF LEANING WITH
GREG.
DUDE, HE HAS BEEN WAY OVER THIS
NUMBER SO MANY TIMES, HE IS AN
ANIMAL.
IF WE ARE GOING TO TRUST ANYONE
TO GET OVER THAT NUMBER, IT IS
HIM.
>> LOEB?
WHO IS GOING TO BLOW OUT WHO?
>> IN SACRAMENTO?
>> I HEAR YOU.
THE KINGS PLAY WELL IN
SACRAMENTO.
I WILL SAY THAT.
THEY LIKE THE BEAM IN
SACRAMENTO.
THE KINGS PLAY WELL THERE.
>> BROTHER, YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT SACRAMENTO LIKE IT IS THE
GARDEN.
THEY WOULD BE LUCKY IF 15% OF
THEIR ATTENDANCE HIT.
WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE?
>> THEY HAVE BEEN SELLING OUT,
BRO.
>> BECAUSE THE ARENA HAS 20
SEATS TOTAL?
>> IF THE PLAYOFFS WERE
TOMORROW, THE KINGS WOULD BE IN
IT.
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW.
>> INTERESTING GIVING
SACRAMENTO THIS MUCH LOVE.
>> I AM JUST SAYING, I THINK IT
IS MORE OF A JOKER DISCUSSION
AND LESS OF A KINGS DISCUSSION.
I WORRY ABOUT THE BLOWOUT, BUT
HE IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PLAYERS.
IF WE WANT TO LOCK IT IN, I AM
IN.
>> WORRY ABOUT THE BLOWOUT, DO
WE JUST TAKE NUGGETS MONEYLINE?
THIS IS A PARLAY.
WE DON'T HAVE TO KEEP DOING.
>> THAT IS A GOOD LIEN.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH THE
NUGGETS MONEYLINE.
>> WHAT IS THIS BREAD?
CAN WE GO UP?
>> MAYBE THEY COULD COVER, GREG
. THEY DON'T HAVE TO WIN.
>> THEY ARE 9-6 AT HOME.
THAT IS DECENT.
>> IT IS ABOVE AVERAGE.
>> WE HAVE TO GET A PICK IN.
>> I KIND OF LIKE THE NUGGETS.
WHAT IS THE LINE?
LET ME SEE.
-4?
THIS LOOKS CRAPPY TO ME. BUT AS
LONG AS I AM ON RECORD SAYING
THAT AND --
>> I CAN'T DO THIS AGAIN WITH
YOU!
IF WE WANT TO DO THE PRA, THE
PRA WAS DROPPED.
IF WE WANT TO DO THE PRA SO
BADLY, I'M IN.
BUT WE HAVE TO START ADJUSTING
SOME OF THE LINES.
I DON'T NEED TO TAKE A -120 FOR
A FIVE SECOND PARLAY.
>> I TOTALLY HEAR YOU.
>> WE WILL TAKE THE PRA.
THAT IS WHAT THE CHAT DROPPED.
ALSO I SEE SACRAMENTO FANS GOT
RYAN.
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH SACRAMENTO
FANS TO COME GET HIM.
>> SACRAMENTO WILL COME AFTER
YOU, BRO.
THOSE FANS ARE LOYAL.
THEY'VE BEEN LOSING FOR I DON'T
KNOW HOW LONG, AND THEY STILL
SHOW UP TO GAMES AND SELLOUT
THAT ARENA.
THEY ARE LOYAL.
SOMETHING IN THE WATER IN
SACRAMENTO.
I DON'T KNOW.
BUT THEY ARE LOYAL TO THOSE
KINGS.
YOU HAD BETTER BE CAREFUL.
>> I THINK THE OPPOSING TEAM'S
FANS ARE THE ONES SELLING OUT
THAT ARENA.
>> ALL RIGHT, RYAN.
I HAVE SOME CONTACTS UP THERE.
I CAN GET YOU TO COME ALONG FOR
A TOUR.
>> HERE WE GO, NOW WE ARE
TALKING.
I GOT A REALLY INTERESTING ONE
FROM PHILIP MARQUEZ.
LUKE CANARD OVER TWO THREES.
HIS LAST FIVE GAMES FOR THREE,
4-8, 2-4, 497.
AND I HAVE BEEN COOKING ON
THESE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU FOR GIVING US
THE PLAY AND THE HANDICAP IN
THE COMMENTS.
THAT IS A ONE STUFF.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> WAS I MISSING SOMETHING?
OR DID I NOT SEE A LUKE CANARD?
MAYBE THEY WON'T ALLOW AND DO
TWO THREES.
>> IS NOT EVEN HERE FOR THE
REGULAR.
>> THAT IS BIZARRE.
>> AND LESSIE GOT TRADED FROM
THE CLIPPERS OVERNIGHT AND HE
IS ON A DIFFERENT TEAM.
BUT THAT IS --
>> SEE, THEY KNOW.
YOU KNOW HOW TO MULTITASK.
THE COMMENTS WANT TO NOTE DO
YOU HATE PHILLY OR SAGAMORE?
>> SAM RICHMAN JUMPS IN HERE,
RYAN HAS NEVER BEEN TO
CALIFORNIA AND IT SHOWS.
I'VE BEEN USING CISCO, LET'S
RELAX.
I HAVE BEEN TO CALIFORNIA
BEFORE.
SACRAMENTO OR PHILLY.
IT IS PHILLY.
IT'S NOT EVEN CLOSE.
I'VE NEVER EVEN BEEN TO
SACRAMENTO.
AND MORE TO THE POINT, THERE'S
NO REASON TO GO TO SACRAMENTO.
>> BRO, YOU ARE BEING SO
DISRESPECTFUL RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS THE CAPITAL OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS THE PRESTIGIOUS CAPITAL
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE GREAT CITY OF SACRAMENTO.
>> THAT MEANS NOTHING TO ME.
IT IS THE CONNECTICUT OF THE
WEST COAST.
NOBODY GOES THERE.
IF YOU ARE IN CALIFORNIA, YOU
ARE DRIVING RIGHT BY SACRAMENTO
TO GET TO EITHER LOS ANGELES OR
SAN FRANCISCO.
MAYBE EVEN SAN DIEGO.
>> THAT I KNOW YOU DON'T KNOW
GEOGRAPHY, BECAUSE YOU DON'T
DRIVE THROUGH SACRAMENTO TO GET
TO EITHER OF THOSE PLACES.
>> WE HAVE TO COOK THIS PARLAY
AND STOP TALKING ABOUT
SACRAMENTO.
PLEASE, GOD.
>> RYAN HAS NEVER SEEN LADY
BIRD AND IT SHOWS.
I HAVE SEEN LADY BIRD!
I HAVE BEEN TO CALIFORNIA AND I
HAVE SEEN LADY BIRD!
>> ALL RIGHT, LET'S LOCK IN THE
PLAY.
WE NEED A PLAY.
WE ARE AT +201.
I THINK IT IS TIME TO START THE
ALTERNATE SPREAD THING.
YOU KNOW HOW WE DO.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
>> WE GO BACK TO THE BAR
ROCKETS?
YES.
ROCKETS +25?
>> LOVE IT.
LOVE THAT.
ABSOLUTELY LOVE THAT.
THERE'S NO WAY THAT DOESN'T HIT.
>> LET'S LOCK IT IN.
LET'S LOCK IT IN.
I LIKE THAT.
+25.
THAT HAS ME FEELING REAL
CONFIDENT.
AGAINST YOUR BOSTON CELTICS.
>> LOOK AT THIS.
-410, THAT IS GREAT VALUE.
>> GREAT VALUE.
LOCK THAT WENT IN.
>> I AM HONESTLY, I AM LAYING
OUT SO YOU GUYS CAN JUST HAVE
YOUR TIME.
THIS IS THE FUNNIEST THING I'VE
EVER SEEN.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE STATE
CAPITAL OF CALIFORNIA FOR 20
MINUTES AND THEN WE PUT A -410
PLAY IN HERE.
THAT IS THE CRAZIEST THING I'VE
EVER BEEN A PART OF.
>> WE ARE LOOKING FOR SCOOPS.
>> UNCLE MATT JUMPS IN HERE,
THAT PRA IS A TRAP.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS 10 MINUTES
AGO.
>> WE TALK ABOUT SACRAMENTO TOO
MUCH, THIS IS TOO MUCH.
>> ALSO JUMPING IN TALKING
ABOUT AL HORFORD OVER THREE
POINTS.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
HE HAS BEEN HOT.
DOES HE EVEN HIT THREES?
>> HE DOES.
HE WAS SMACKING THEM ON
CHRISTMAS.
SMACKING THEM.
AS SOMEONE WHO TOOK SIMPLEST
POINTS, HE WAS ON FIRE.
>> YES, SIR.
THIS WAS A GOOD PLAY.
HE HAS GOT THE SHARP PLAYS.
AND I WATCHED THAT GAME.
THAT WAS A PRETTY GOOD GAME.
OBVIOUSLY TATUM WENT OFF.
BUT HORFORD IS ALWAYS HANGING
ON THE CORNER MAKING THREES.
HE IS PRETTY RELIABLE.
>> AND I ASK UNCLE NOW?
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT OVER 2.5?
BECAUSE THAT IS VERY JUICY.
OR ARE YOU TALKING TO PLUS?
>> LET'S GO 2+.
>> THAT WOULD BE -210.
THAT PUTS US IN A GOOD SPOT.
I LIKE THAT.
>> I LIKE IT.
2+.
>> HE SAID HE SAID IT 10
MINUTES AGO.
SORRY.
WE ARE SLANDERING SACRAMENTO.
THAT'S MY BAD.
THAT PUTS US AT A GOOD SPOT TO
ADD SOMETHING LIKE SOMEWHAT
SAFE IS THE FIFTH LEG. I MY
GOAL IS TO GET THIS TO +600.
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GUYS
FEEL, BUT I FEEL PRETTY GOOD
ABOUT THIS.
THE SPOT WE ARE IN.
LEONARD OVER POINTS, 20 POINTS.
>> OKAY.
ARE WE CONCERNED WITH THE
CLIPPERS ON A BACK TO BACK?
>> I THINK YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO BE
. ANYTHING WITH KELLY LEONARD
IN THE BACK TO BACK, YOU ARE
HEAVILY CONCERNED.
>> THEY ALMOST LOST LAST NIGHT
BECAUSE THE CLIPPERS IN A
MONEYLINE.
THEY PLAYED THE PISTONS.
THEY WERE DOWN 14 LATE, PUT IN
THE SCRUB SQUAD, AND THE SCRUB
SQUAD CAME ALL THE WAY BACK AND
WON IN OVERTIME.
THEY PLAYED AN OVERTIME GAME
YESTERDAY.
I, THIS IS MY ADVOCATING FOR
RAPTORS MONEYLINE.
>> SOMEONE PUT THAT IN THE CHAT
EARLIER.
SOMEBODY HAD IT IN HERE.
I'M GOING TO GO BACK AND LOOK.
SOMEONE WAS LIKE SECOND GAME
BACK TO BACK, CLIPPERS ON THE
ROAD IN TORONTO.
COULD YOU IMAGINE? LOOKS LIKE
HE DIDN'T PLAY LAST NIGHT.
SO WE ARE DEFINITELY.
THAT IS A NARRATIVE.
HE IS GOING BACK TO TORONTO.
LET'S GO.
THAT'S A GOOD SCHOOL.
>> THAT IS A GOOD SCHOOL.
FLIP DOLLAR IS 6-6 FROM THE
FIELD IN THE CHAT TONIGHT.
AND I LOVE IT.
THE GUYS THROWING IN SOME GOOD
HEAT.
>> THAT IS A GREAT SCOOP.
>> I'M GOING TO DOUBLE CHECK
AND MAKE SURE HE DID NOT PLAY
LAST NIGHT.
>> YEAH, DOUBLE CHECK THAT.
IF HE DIDN'T PLAY LAST NIGHT
AND HE IS COMING BACK, WE ARE
WRITING WITH HIM.
WE ARE WRITING
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY THIS GIVES
ME, RYAN, NO.
YOU HAVE DONE THIS PLENTY OF
TIMES, NO.
WE ARE WRITING.
WE ARE ROCKING WITH KAWHI.
WE GOT A SCOOP HE DID NOT PLAY
LAST NIGHT, HE'S GOING BACK TO
TORONTO, HE'S GOING TO BALL.
WE ARE WRITING.
YOU FILL IT WITH US.
JUST FAKE IT.
>> I'M NOT A FAKE IT TILL YOU
MAKE IT GUY.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS.
THIS LINE IS VERY JUICED UP.
SO THERE'S THAT.
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE EVERYONE IN
AMERICA AND OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS UP IN CANADA IS
PROBABLY BETTING ON THIS OVER.
DO WE WANT TO TEASE IT DOWN TO
15+?
>> LET'S SEE.
WHY NOT.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT IT SAYS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I KIND OF LIKE IT.
I DON'T HATE IT.
I THINK WE HAVE TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION, LOKI, ABOUT THE
JOKER LEG. I AM SEEING A LOT OF
CHAT SAYING THAT IS GOING TO BE
THE LEG THAT SMOKES US.
>> KNOW.
I'M TELLING YOU. I'M TELLING
YOU.
>> I LOVE WHEN GREG IS LIKE I
AM TELLING YOU, BECAUSE
NORMALLY WHEN HE SAYS THAT IT
DOES HIT.
BUT WE ALWAYS KIND OF GO OFF OF
IT.
LIKE THE GREG LEG.
WE GOT THE GREG LEG IN.
AND IT.
I'M FEELING THE VIBE.
IF YOU SAY IT IS GOOD, IT IS
GOOD.
>> I'M TELLING YOU.
LET'S LET THAT MAN COOK.
LET'S WATCH AND REJOICE.
LET'S CELEBRATE TONIGHT.
BECAUSE I REALLY LIKE THIS
PARLAY.
I REALLY DO LIKE THIS PARLAY.
>> THE CHAT LIKES IT TOO.
B THOMPSON SAYS THAT ON THE.
>> B THOMPSON SAYS LET IT RIDE.
JOKER PRA, TRAP.
WE HAVE GOT TO GIVE LOVE TO THE
NEGATIVE COMMENTS.
WE CAN'T JUST CHERRY PICK.
AS SOMEONE WHO CHERRY PICKS
EVERY WEEK THE COMMENTS THAT HE
READS, WE HAVE TO GIVE LOVE TO
SOME OF THESE NEGATIVE
COMMENTS.
>> IT IS OKAY.
>> MY GUY, LOGAN.
CAN WE DO LeBRON 25+ INSTEAD?
HE HAS HAD 30 AND SEVEN
STRAIGHT GAMES.
>> THAT MEANS NOTHING TO ME.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
BUT THEY ARE PLAYING THE MAGIC.
HE IS GOING TO COOK.
>> OH, MY GOSH, YOU GUYS.
OKAY.
WHY DON'T WE JUST ADDED AS A
LEG.
>> I'M DOWN, BRO.
I DON'T EVEN CARE, MAN.
THIS IS HILARIOUS.
IF WE HAVE A SIX LEG WITH
LeBRON, WHICH WE KNOW IS GOING
TO HIT, WE ARE STILL GOING TO
SWEAT THE JOKER PROP ANYWAY.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO GET A BUNCH
OF MONEY.
>> I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHY WE
ARE SWEATING ABOUT JOKIC.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE EAST  IS
BLOCK OF THE NIGHT.
>> I LOVE THIS SO MUCH.
THIS IS AMAZING.
>> CAN WE DO SOMETHING DOWN
WITH JOKIC?
IF WE ADD LeBRON, WE CAN DO
SOMETHING DOWN WITH JOKIC.
I WILL BE DOWN WITH THAT.
>> HERE WE GO.
THIS IS WHERE I LIKE TO GO.
>> SO HOW DO WE TEASE DOWN THE
POINTS, REBOUNDS, AND ASSISTS?
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DO THAT.
>> I WAS GOING TO OFFER
SOMETHING UP THERE. BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK WE CAN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE FEEL ABOUT
THAT, BUT IF WE WERE CONFIDENT
IN POINTS, REBOUNDS, AND
ASSIST, WE WERE PRETTY MUCH
CONFIDENT IN EVERY STEP AND
CATEGORY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I LOVE THE WAY YOU ARE
THINKING.
LET'S CONTINUE TO TALK.
LET'S CONTINUE TO DIALOGUE.
>> I'M ON ONE TODAY.
>> WE MIGHT BE GOING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE MIGHT BE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
SO CONTINUE.
PLEASE.
>> I TOLD BOWLING THIS.
I DEALT WITH THREE TIMES SQUARE
BUZZ LIGHT YEARS TODAY.
THROUGHOUT THE CITY, I AM STILL
STANDING.
>> A PHOENIX REST OF THE ASHES.
>> IS ASSIST ALWAYS TREATED US
WELL.
I FEEL LIKE ENTASIS IS PROBABLY
WHERE WE COULD NET OUT AND FEEL
COMFORTABLE.
IT DOESN'T DO WHAT I WANTED TO
DO.
WE CAN MESS AROUND, TINKER THIS
AND TEASE DOWN THE ROCKETS
LITTLE BIT.
MAYBE TO 22.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK THE
ROCKETS MIGHT ACTUALLY WIN
TONIGHT.
SO I'M DOWN TO TEASE THEM DOWN.
>> I AM DOWN TO TEASE THAT
DOWN.
>> A HUGE BLOWOUT, IF WE LOSE
BY 23 WE STILL CASH, I'M DOWN.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE WHAT
UNCLE MAO  HAS TO SAY.
>> WIRE WE SINGLING HIM OUT?
>> IS ONE OF OUR COMMUNITY
CAPTAINS, AND HE IS DEFINITELY
LUCKY.
HE HAS THE BLAZE.
I AM DEFINITELY MORE ON BOARD
WITH THE JOKER PLAYED THEN
MAYBE A LOT OF PEOPLE.
I THINK IT IS JUST ME AND YOU
AGAINST THE WORLD.
BUT IF HE SAYS LOOK AT THE
MELLOW THREES, WE SHOULD TAKE A
PEEK.
>> AS THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE, IF
I DON'T KNOW YOU THEN YOUR
CREDIBILITY MIGHT BE IN THE
AIR.
SO YOU HAVE GOT TO TAP IN.
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
YOU HAVE TO TAP IN. BECAUSE
THIS WHOLE SHOW, OUR WHOLE
PARLAY IS WRITING ON YOU.
THAT'S WHAT IT SEEMS LIKE.
IT IS WRITING ON YOU AND WHAT
YOU ARE TRYING TO DO.
SO TAPPAN.
PLEASE TAPPAN.
HOW ARE WE LOOKING ON THE
PARLAY?
>> SIX LEG IS THE ONLY +7.
>> SIX LEG?
>> IT WOULD GO TO LAMELO THREES
, WE ONLY HAVE SIX LEG.
A SEVENTH LIKE IS OFF THE TABLE
FOR ME.
>> I WOULD ARGUE THAT MAYBE WE
NEED TO TAKE AWAY A LEG
ALREADY.
>> ME TOO, RYAN.
I AM IN THE SAME BOAT.
SIX LEGS FOR +474 IS NOT
ENOUGH.
IT'S NOT DOING IT.
>> I'M KIND OF ON BOARD, BUT
WHAT ARE WE TAKING OUT?
JUST TO REVIEW FOR EVERYBODY,
WE HAVE HOUSTON ROCKETS +25.5.
PALO BANCHERO , +26 POINTS.
THAT IS THE LOGAN LEG.
AND THEN WE HAVE KAWHI , 15+
POINTS, AND JOKIC, A+ ASSISTS.
>> HONESTLY, I DON'T KNOW.
THE ENVIRONMENT IN SACRAMENTO
IS SO ROWDY.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS GOING TO
BE ABLE TO GET HIS ASSISTS UP
TO EIGHT.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T HATE THE IDEA OF JUST
TOSSING IN THE THREES.
I DON'T CARE.
LITERALLY 30 SECONDS AGO I GOT
SEVEN LEGS IS OFF THE TABLE AND
BOWLING AGREED, NOW WE ARE AT A
POINT WHERE WE HAVE A +900
SEVEN LEG PARLAY.
>> THAT THAT IS FUN.
THAT IS WHAT THE PEOPLE WANT.
THE PEOPLE WANT THAT.
SAYING YOU ARE PLAYING IT TOO
SAFE.
TAKE 20 POINTS AND DENVER
MONEYLINE.
ARE WE BEING TO SAY?
>> NO, I THINK WE ARE BEING
RECKLESS.
RECKLESS AS ALL RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THAT IS WHAT WE NEED TO
DO.
IF WE ARE GOING TO DO THIS, WE
NEED TO TEASE DOWN EVERYTHING
ELSE WE HAVE PUT IN HERE.
>> I THINK WHAT I WAS SAYING
WAS INSTEAD OF DOING 15 POINTS,
LET'S DO 20.
>> NO, NO, I KNOW YOU ARE
SAYING.
I'M SAYING I WOULD RATHER GO
DOWN.
DO YOU GET WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> YOU LOST ME.
>> I WOULD RATHER US, IF WE ARE
GOING TO LEAN ON HIM HERE AND
GO LAMELO OVER 3.5 THREES,
WHICH IS A LOT, BY THE WAY,
THEN I WOULD LIKE THE OTHER
LEGS TO MAKE  SWEAT LESS.
SO RATHER THAN TRY AND CHOOSE
THIS BABY ON THE WAY OUT, LET'S
JUST KNOCK IT DOWN A FEW PEGS.
>> SO WHAT YOU ARE SAYING IS
TAKE LeBRON 20 POINTS INSTEAD
OF 25.
>> LOOKING AT EVERYTHING ELSE,
YEAH.
YOU CAN ALSO PROBABLY TAUGHT ME
INTO JOKIC  6+ ASSISTS.
>> IS GOING TO GET A DESIST.
>> YEAH.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE LeBRON STUFF
DOES HERE.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET RID OF YOU.
>> FLIP DOLLARS THAT SEVEN IS
GOD AND HE GOT US.
>> JOKER PRA WAS THE MONEY.
EXACTLY.
WE ARE SEVEN LEGS IN. RYAN, IN
YOUR HEART YOU DON'T EVEN DO
THINGS LIKE THIS.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING RIGHT NOW?
>> I KNOW.
I AM A FOUR-LEGGED PARLAY GUY.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
YOU ARE SEVEN LEGS AND +700?
BUT JOKER IN.
>> YOU CAN'T JUMP IN HERE AND
SAY TAKE THE OVER THREES AND
THEN WANT TO TEASE IT DOWN.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> HE MIGHT HAVE SAID OVER 3+.
SO THIS IS THE PARLAY.
LET'S JUST CALL IT.
WE MIGHT AS WELL BRANDED THAT
WAY.
BECAUSE THIS GUY HAS SO MUCH
PULL ON OUR PARLAY.
>> I THINK WE ARE ALL MISSING
THE POINT.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF IT WAS HIS
ORIGINAL PLAY.
HE WAS JUST TRYING TO PUSH IT
TO THE FOREFRONT BECAUSE HE
THINGS IT IS A LOT.
IF WE GET THREE THREES IN
THERE, WHAT DOES IT DO?
BECAUSE I AM READY TO GO DRINK
A BEER.
THIS IS A STRESSFUL SHOW.
>> I NEED SOMETHING STRONGER
THAN BEER AFTER THIS.
WE ARE AT SEVEN LEGS OF +531.
WHY ARE WE PUTTING IN LAMELO
BALL TO MAKE 33 IS AT -390.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
WHEN WE CAN GO GET JOKIC  PRA
AT -110, -120.
BUT WE WANT TO PUT OUR FAITH IN
. BROKEN SHOT .  EVEN THOUGH HE
HAS BEEN SHOOTING BETTER, BUT
WE WANT TO PUT OUR FAITH IN ?
>> JUST GO BACK AND PUT THE
JOKER PRA N, AND LET'S GO WITH
OUR GOD.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO DO.
>> THIS IS WHAT I WANT.
FOR OUR SOCIAL MEDIA PEOPLE WHO
CLIPPED THE SHOW OUT, CLIPPED
THAT LITTLE RANT TOGETHER FROM
GREG AND WE ARE BRANDING THIS
IS THE GREG LEG.
I WANT THIS AS THE GREG LEG
NEXT TO IT.
AND WHATEVER GRAPHIC THAT WE
PUT.
THIS GUY IS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
AND WE ARE BELIEVING IN HIM.
HE IS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
THIS IS THE MOST INTERACTIVE WE
HAVE GOTTEN.
GOING TO GET IN THE MILK.
WHERE IS THE MILK CARTON THAT.
GIVE US OUR PRA AND LET'S GET
OUT OF HERE.
>> I TOOK OUT LeBRON.
NOW HE IS TALKING ABOUT
APPROVED.
YOU CRAZY, BRO.
>> LeBRON IS OUT.
THIS IS OUR NEW SIX PARLAY.
HOUSTON ROCKETS +25.5.
AL HORFORD +2 MADE THREES.
PALO BANCHERO , 20+ POINTS.
KAWHI LEONARD, 15+ POINTS.
, 15 MADE  THREES.
>> TAKE LAMELO OUT .
>> THE LeBRON LEG WAS -5000,
THEN JOKIC OVER 40.5.
>> YES, -5000 FOR REASON.
I WOULD MUCH RATHER TAKE --
>> WEIGHT. WE TEASED LeBRON
DOWN TO 20 BECAUSE WE HAD THE
OTHER STUFF IN.
WE ORIGINALLY WANTED 125.
IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE LeBRON
IN, JUST GO BACK TO 25.
>> ARE WE TAKING LAMELO OUT?
>> YES, PLEASE TAKE LAMELO
OUT.
>> OKAY, Z SAID KEEP LeBRON,
TAKE HORFORD OUT.
>> WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T REALLY LIKE HORFORD
THREE IS EITHER.
LeBRON 25 POINTS, HORFORD IS
OUT, BALL IS OUT, PRESS THE
BUTTON.
>> I DON'T THINK WE ARE EVER
TAKING BALL OUT.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE DOING.
I DON'T INC.
--
>> THAT IS WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
>> BROTHER, THERE'S GOING TO BE
NO JUICE LEFT IN THAT.
>> IS -390, WHAT USE IS THAT?
TAKEN OUT AND PUT LeBRON BACK
IN +325 AND WE ARE GOOD.
>> GOODNESS GRACIOUS.
SO I'M TAKING OUT LAMELO?
WHAT WOULD THIS DOES.
WHAT THIS DOES.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER!
>> I THINK WE ARE BACK TO WHERE
WE STARTED.
>> THAT'S THE POINT.
>> WHERE WE STARTED WASN'T
GOOD!
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE LEFT!
>> ARE WE OKAY WITH THIS?
>> READ IT OUT AGAIN.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS JUICIER
THAN THAT.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING,
GREG.
WE ARE REPLACING STUFF.
WE ARE GOING BACK AND FORTH,
BACK AND FORTH, THE ENTIRE TIME
I'M SAYING LOOK AT WHAT WE ARE
DOING TO THE ODDS.
AND NO ONE IS LISTENING.
>> I FEEL LIKE RYAN IS GOING TO
GO ON A WF A STYLE RANT.
>> MY GOODNESS, THE BUZZ LAYERS
ARE FINALLY GETTING TO ME.
PABLO BANCHERO , +25 POINTS.
KAWHI LEONARD, 15+ POINTS.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE DID .
>> WE NEED TO.
I CAN'T TAKE MONEY PLUS WITH
KAWHI.
>> THE ROCKETS WERE THE MOVE.
TO MOVE IT DOWN TO 22.
ALSO, I'M BEING TOLD, AND I
KNOW THIS, THAT WE TOOK AL
HORFORD OUT AND THAT'S WHY WE
LOST THE JUICE.
I'M JUST SAYING THAT AL HORFORD
DOES NOT SEEM LIKE A POPULAR
PLAY.
WE NEED TO FIGURE SOMETHING.
LEONARD IS GOING TO BALL.
WHY ARE WE GOING 15 POINTS WITH
KAWHI?
BRING THAT UP TO 20.
BRING THAT UP TO 20, MAN.
BUT THAT TO 20 AND LET'S SEND
IT.
AND WATCH WHAT IT DOES.
PUT THAT UP TO 20 AND WATCH
WHAT IT DOES.
YOU'RE GOING TO LIKE IT.
>> -125.
YEAH, I DON'T LIKE IT.
I LOVE IT.
BUT PUT THAT THING IN AND LET'S
RIDE.
THERE IT IS.
THAT'S WHAT YOU LIKE.
THAT'S YOUR TYPE OF BUY.
THAT'S YOUR TYPE OF PARLAY.
THAT IS ALL YOU, BRO.
>> DON'T DO THIS.
DON'T DO THIS IT'S ALL ME.
BECAUSE THEN WHEN THIS LOSES,
YEAH, RIGHT.
THEN WHEN THIS LOSES I'M GOING
TO HAVE TO FACE THE MUSIC.
DON'T DO THIS.
>> LET'S GET OUT OF HERE, BRO.
WE NEED TO PARLAY FOR THE
PEOPLE.
>> PABLO BANCHERO , 25 POINTS.
LeBRON JAMES, +25 POINTS.
HOUSTON ROCKETS, +25.5.
JOKIC,  THEN KAWHI LEONARD, 20+
POINTS.
FIVE LEG PARLAY.
THAT ADDS UP TO +734.
>> I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW, THE
CHAT IS ABSOLUTELY HYSTERICAL.
ALL OF THESE GAMES AND YOU CAN'T
TOGETHER A FIVE TEAM.
GET IT TOGETHER, Y'ALL ARE
LOST.
>> THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
HELPING US!
>> THIS IS SO GOOD.
I CAN'T WAIT TO BET  THIS WITH
MY $20 FREE BET AND CASH OUT.
>> WHAT PICK DID HE GIVE US?
>> DID WE TAKE IT OUT?
>> WE TOOK THEM BOTH OUT.
>> PUT YOUR PICKS IN THE CHAT.
IF YOU HIT, WE HAVE GOT US INTO
THE GAME.
WE HAVE DESCEND INTO A RIDE
ALONG OR SOMETHING.
WE HAVE TO SEND THEM TO A GAME,
SEND TO A RIDE ALONG, INC.
WE WANT TO SEE YOU GUYS THAT
COME TO THIS SHOW EVERY WEEK.
WE WANT TO GIVE BACK TO YOU
GUYS.
SO YOU ARE GOING TO BE OUR
FIRST ONE.
YOUR LOCKS IN THE CHAT, AND IF
YOU HIT WE WILL HIGHLY CONSIDER
BRINGING YOU TO THE NEXT ROUTER
BALL.
ALSO, IF YOU HAVE WON IN THE
WHOLE CALENDAR YEAR, YOUR TEST
WINS FOR THE NBA SEASON, TAP IN
WITH US AND DROP THEM IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WE ARE GIVING OUT MURCH.
>> THERE IT IS.
GIVE IT TO US ONE MORE TIME,
THEN WE ARE ABOUT TO GET UP OUT
OF HERE.
TRY TO DRINK A BEER, TRYING TO
WIN SOME THAT'S.
>> I'M THE ONLY ONE WHO DIDN'T
GIVE SOMETHING AWAY IN THAT
SPEECH.
THAT WHOLE LITTLE SPIEL.
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO GIVE
AWAY.
I GUESS IF YOU'RE FROM
SACRAMENTO DON'T END UP.
PABLO BANCHERO,  +25 POINTS
VERY LeBRON JAMES, +25 POINTS.
HOUSTON ROCKETS, +25.5 AGAINST
THE BOSTON CELTICS.
JOKIC,  REBOUNDS AND ASSISTS,
THE NUGGETS BLOW OUT OF THE
KINGS TONIGHT.
THEN KAWHI LEONARD, 20+ POINTS
IN HIS RETURN TO THE SIX . IN
TWO OF THOSE WERE SPLIT DOLLAR
23.
DON'T CATCH ME CALLING IT THE
FLIP DOLLAR PARLAY.
IF IT DOESN'T HIT. IF IT
DOESN'T HIT.
I THOUGHT IT HAD A RING TO IT.
THAT'S IT, WE ARE UP OUT OF
HERE.
MY NAME IS GREG, NEXT TO ME IS
IN BE.
NEXT TO HIM IS THE GUY WE LIKE
TO CALL THE MR. I TOLD YOU SO
GUY.
PRODUCER RYAN.
>> I THOUGHT MAN OF THE PEOPLE
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN.
ONE OF THESE DAYS.
>> A MAN OF THE PEOPLE.
WE ARE UP OUT OF HERE.
LET'S GO WITH SOME MONEY.